-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy
and Peabody award-winning
producer,
a "New York Times"
best-selling author,
and the host of "Watch What
Happens Live With Andy Cohen,"
which airs Sunday through
Thursday nights on Bravo.
Please welcome back to the show,
our good friend Andy Cohen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's so good to see you again.
-It's so good to see you again.
-I got to see you recently.
I got to do your show
on St. Patrick's day.
-That was so fun.
-It's so much fun.
-You didn't get drunk enough.
-You know, the thing --
-Specially considering
the weight of the date.
-It was St. Patrick's Day,
and I'm always very excited
to go to your show because I do
feel like it's
a professional excuse
to get drunk.
-I do, too.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
-But you know, your show --
and I say this as a huge
compliment --
the pace is breakneck.
-It is.
-It moves so fast.
-Yes.
I have a short attention span.
-Yeah.
-So, it's about if I can keep
myself engaged for 30 minutes...
-Yeah.
-...then it's good.
That's why I'm always
changing the topic.
-You know, it's like trying to
have a drink, I would imagine,
during speed dating where...
-Yeah.
-...there's no time to actually
get the wine in your mouth
because you only have
five minutes to do...
-Yeah. Somehow I'm able to get
the sips in.
I know when to drink.
-You know what?
That's where I should -- I
should learn from you.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Last time you were here,
it was before the pandemic
and we were celebrating
the 10th anniversary of
"Watch What Happens Live."
-Yeah.
-13 years now.
-13 years.
-Really amazing.
-I know. I'm still -- I can't
believe we're still going.
It's great. I'm so lucky.
-Yeah.
I mean, I feel the same way,
and we're at eight.
-Yes.
-You know, and the thing --
and again, going back to just
the way this show moves
and the flow of it,
it does not seem like
it's a show you could
do if you were bored with it.
-That's true.
-Yeah.
-Although,
have you hit a wall yet?
Was there ever a point
in your eight years
where you were like kind of
ticking a box?
-I think m-- I will say
that if I got close to it,
the pandemic reset the clock,
you know what I mean?
-Yes, of course.
-Because all of a sudden
you go back and you appreciate
everything a lot more.
-You're like, "whoa,
I'm so lucky to have this."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Whereas right before
the pandemic,
I remember saying, like, "God!
I dare you to do something!"
-Right, yes.
-[ Indistinct ]
-Congratulations on your book.
-Thank you very much.
It's not here anymore, yeah.
-Yeah, right.
We are really enjoying it.
-This is your 3-year-old son,
Ben?
-Yes. I e-mailed you.
I was a little upset because
there are a lot of
words in the book.
-Yeah. You -- right.
-Yes.
-Going back to your
attention span.
-I lodged a formal complaint
with Seth because when he hands
me a super wordy book, I'm like,
"Oh, really?
This is what you want?"
There is a book called
"Big Bug and Little Bug."
-Okay?
-There is not even
an author credited.
It is such a pamphlet,
but he loves it and it's
literally like,
"A little bug
fell in a hole he dug."
-Yeah.
-Next page.
And I'm like, "This is --"
I'm like,
"Want to read
'Little Bug, Big Bug'?"
-So you try to push -- you try
to push the simple stuff,
yeah, yeah.
The most heartbreaking thing
is when someone says --
when you write
an illustrated children's book
that is 32 pages
and someone said,
"We started it."
-No!
-Yes.
-Someone had said that to you?
-Someone had said to me,
like, "We started it."
I'm like, "Started it?"
-That is terrible. Wow.
And when Jimmy Fallon said that
to you, you said what?
[ Laughter ]
-I said what I always say. I'm
like, "You're the man, Jimmy!"
[ Laughter ]
"Whatever you say, boss!"
[ Laughs ]
Your mom, I know,
is a huge fan of your
in your entirety,
your being.
But does she still watch
the show 13 years in?
-She does.
I mean, and she --
she has very mixed reviews
about my show.
-That's so lovely.
-Always -- we had --
her most recent gripe, which
really she was on for a while,
we had Laura Linney and
Kristin Davis on one night.
-Very nice combo.
-Great actresses.
And my parents are big
"Ozark" fans,
and we played a game called
"Have They Crapped Their Pants?"
Where I showed them a celebrity,
and they have to say, guess,
whether the celebrity
had, in fact,
publicly admitted to crapping
their pants.
-Yeah.
-Fun game, right?
-It is a fun game.
-There's a play-at-home factor.
-Yeah.
-And my mom was so mad at me
for for smearing Laura Linney
in that way and bringing her
down to my level,
I did not hear about --
the texts I got were so brutal.
And then, yeah, it was bad.
-Do you -- do look back at that
and think you should have
known better once you knew you
had someone your parents loved
like Laura Linney?
Should you have, like,
pushed "Crapped My Pants"
a show?
-No, because I think it's the
dichotomy of someone so
brilliant that's Laura Linney...
-Yeah.
-...and playing the game
with her.
-You're right.
-I think, yes, no.
I think we did the right thing,
and I'm sorry I upset my
mother.
-But you put the show first.
-I do.
-I will say,
I think of all the interviews
Laura Linney has ever done,
that's the only time she's
played that game. [ Laughs ]
-You think?
-I think so. I think.
Hey, we --
it was so joyous to
us.
Anything that happens these
days that is just pure joy.
-Yes.
-And even though this wasn't
necessarily positive --
You were pretty upset --
but this is you and Anderson
on New Year's Eve.
You got a little bit...
-Oh, you have the clip?
-We have a clip, yeah.
-Oh, boy.
-I mean, we -- I got to
be honest, Andy.
We've shown it a lot.
We never get tired of it.
And I would like -- here is --
You'll know what this is about
in a second.
-Watching Mayor de Blasio...
-Don't go on a rant.
-...do his victory-lap dance
after four years
of the crappiest term as the
mayor of New York...
-That's how you want to start
the new year?
-The only thing that Democrats
and Republicans can agree on
is what a horrible mayor he has
been, so sayonara, sucka!
-I mean, I will say...
[ Applause ]
...message aside, it is --
you two --
you and Anderson complement
each other so well,
and that is my favorite thing to
watch is that two shot
of friendship while you are --
and while he's just --
you just felt like
he was stepping.
-He was pulling my hood.
-[ Laughs ]
-He was pulling me by the hood.
And what I forgot about
that clip is how d-- well,
that I didn't forget,
but how hoarse I was.
-Yes.
-Because I had really been
on my soapbox
at that point
for four or five hours.
I was like, "And this is --
and Journey's fake!
The new Journey is fake!"
-It's so great.
So when you hear someone
yelling that hoarse,
it actually makes you feel
better about the fact
you're getting yelled at
because you're like,
I think they do
a lot of yelling."
-Yeah, exactly. I know.
We got in the car after, and we
were leaving Times Square,
and I went on Twitter
and I looked,
and that clip was on Twitter,
and I was like,
"Oh, this is this
de Blasio thing."
And I was watching it,
and I had fully forgotten
or not realized that I said,
"Sayonara, sucka."
And I turned to Anderson, and I
go, "I said, sayonara, sucka?'"
and he goes, "Yup. You did."
I'm like, "Oh, my God."
-It really is the perfect --
it's the perfect button.
-But by the way, has there
ever been a safer target
than trashing Mayor de Blasio?
-On New Year's Eve,
in Times Square, everything.
-I do regret saying that he had
been Mayor for four years
because it was a very long
eight years.
-Yes, exactly.
-And I hate making an error,
and that was an error.
That was the one error I made.
-I think people forget it.
I have a lot more
to ask you about.
We'll be right back with more
from Andy Cohen after this.